The Umbrella Academy's mind- and time-bending
finale pays off multiple plot threads that
have been quietly simmering in the background,
and drops a ton of new revelations that are
going to have major implications moving forward.
There is no shortage of material here to unpack
and discuss.
Dad the alien
Perhaps the most cryptic scene of all in The
Umbrella Academy's season finale comes right
at the beginning of the episode.
It opens with a flashback: a still-living
Reginald Hargreeves is comforting a woman
who seems to be his lover as she dies of an
unnamed illness.
Outside, dozens of otherworldly spaceships
are exiting the atmosphere, indicating that
this strange world is experiencing its last
moments.
Though never directly stated, we can assume
from this that Reginald Hargreeves is an alien,
something which is also briefly stated in
the comics, but not ever explored deeper.
Also, there is one final inexplicable element.
Before Reginald leaves his homeworld for Earth,
he opens a jar that releases dozens of tiny
firefly-like things which fly up into the
air and vanish.
No explanation is given, but this is undeniably
setting up... something.
All we have now are tin-foil hat theories,
like the idea that there were 43 of those
fireflies, and these were responsible for
the 43 Earth women who gave birth to superpowered
children in the first episode.
If this is the case, it could mean that Hargreeves
created the children as a way of giving the
Earth someone to protect it, as a way of atoning
for failing to protect his own homeworld.
This is pure speculation of course, but it
would explain why Hargreeves was so interested
in adopting as many of these super kids as
possible.
World's worst musician
Once the flashback is over, we're back in
the present, where things are not going well
for what remains of the Hargreeves family.
Vanya has discovered she has the ability to
transform ambient sound into deadly force.
After getting understandably upset at her
family for — intentionally or unintentionally
— belittling her and deceiving her about
her powers throughout her entire life, she
reflexively lashes out, gravely wounding Allison
and killing several others.
Up until now, the rest of the team has been
trying to figure out what's going to cause
the end of the world, but now they realize
the source of the apocalypse is going to be
Vanya.
"I thought Harold Jenkins was the cause, but
he was the fuse, Vanya is the bomb.
Vanya causes the apocalypse."
You see, Vanya's St. Pluvium Chamber Orchestra
has a performance later that day at the Icarus
Theatre, and with her new sound manipulation
powers going out of control, this concert
has the potential to end the world.
What's with the gas masks?
Midway through the episode, a bunch of new
assault rifle-wielding baddies in red gas
masks show up and start trying to kill our
heroes.
It's never stated explicitly where they came
from or who they're working for, but if you
were paying close attention earlier in the
season, you should recognize them instantly.
In episode 6, those same gas masks are hanging
up in the background as the Handler is giving
Number Five a tour of the time travel enforcement
bureau known as the Commission.
So much like Hazel, Cha Cha, and the hit squad
that attacked Number Five at the end of the
first episode, the men in gas masks are additional
agents in service to the Commission.
The late arrival of these masked goons indicates
that we possibly haven't seen the full array
of the different types of agents and resources
that the Commission has at its disposal.
The level of threat they're going to be sending
moving forward will likely just escalate from
here.
Hazel handles the Handler
Early in this episode, it seems Hazel might
be back to working for the wrong side.
The Handler tells him and Cha Cha that if
they can protect Vanya until the apocalypse
hits, they'll both be forgiven for their previous
transgressions.
Hazel agrees at first, but on the way to the
Icarus Theatre, things take a dramatic turn
when he purposefully crashes his car in an
attempt to kill Cha Cha and escape the assignment.
After leaving Cha Cha for dead, Hazel returns
to the Handler's hotel room to free his girlfriend
Agnes, but The Handler stands in his way.
We're expecting another dramatic conversation
in which Hazel and the Handler debate the
merits of their respective worldviews, but
Hazel skips this part and just shoots her
in the head.
You might think this means that his troubles
are over, but when Number Five threatened
to do the same thing to the Handler in episode
five, she warned:
"I'll just be replaced.
I am but a… small cog in a machine."
Even though she acts like the one directing
the entire Commission, the Handler's death
would probably only mean that things will
get worse for our heroes.
Fingers crossed we'll finally get a chance
to meet the big boss from the comic book,
an evil sentient goldfish in a robot body
by the name of Carmichael.
Klaus and Ben level up
During the final battle in the Icarus Theater,
Klaus exhibits a new power for the first time,
channeling the spirit of his dead brother
Ben, who appears in the middle of the room
in a ghostly blue form.
This manifestation of Ben is, however, quite
corporeal, as he is able to use the superpowers
he had when he was alive to create a mass
of super-strong tentacles to tenta-kill the
squad of Commission agents attacking his siblings.
Klaus is able to achieve this new level of
power because he's managed to stay sober for
a while now, which seems to have opened the
door to powers beyond just communicating with
the dead.
If he remains sober into season two, we could
see Klaus use telekinesis and levitation,
a pair of powers he has in the comics, but
lacks in the show.
It's also likely that Klaus' increased ability
to channel Ben into the physical world means
that the second season will give us much more
of Ben, who will also finally get a chance
to interact with other members of the family.
Burying the hatchet
When Diego confronts Cha Cha at the Icarus,
it looks as though he'll finally be able to
have his vengeance over the death of his friend,
Detective Eudora Patch.
At the end of the fight, however, when Diego
has Cha Cha at his mercy, he ends up sparing
her life.
If you were confused as to why, this is actually
a culmination of his journey throughout the
season.
Even before he became consumed with his quest
for revenge, Diego was always one of the morally
murkier Hargreeves children.
The one thing that always kept him from going
off the deep end, however, was his friendship
with Patch.
When Diego finally gets the chance to kill
Cha Cha, he can't help but imagine what Patch
would think of him now.
He remembers a conversation with Five that
he had in episode nine:
"Your girlfriend, Patch.
What did you like about her?"
"She believed in people.
She always saw the good inside.”
Diego realizes that perhaps there was some
good inside Cha Cha as well, even if she herself
hasn't realized it yet, and he decides to
leave her alive so maybe she can also get
a chance to find it someday.
Does this mean that Diego is going to be less
broody in the future?
Probably not, but it's a start.
Going out with a bang
One of the biggest turning points in the Umbrella
Academy season 1 finale comes when Allison
has to decide whether or not Vanya is beyond
saving.
Up until now, Allison has always advocated
attempting to reason with her, but when Vanya
is about to kill not just the four Hargreeves
boys, but also possibly the entire world,
Allison realizes that she might need to be
put down for good.
In the comics, Vanya actually does get shot
in the head at this moment, but it's Five
who pulls the trigger, not Allison.
The comics version of Vanya ends up surviving
the injury, but she's paralyzed and suffers
memory loss.
In the show, however, Allison opts for another
way, placing the gun right beside Vanya's
head and firing.
The sound that close to Vanya's ear is enough
to break her concentration long enough for
the Hargreeves boys to escape.
Even though she falls unconscious, all the
energy Vanya's been gathering up has to go
somewhere.
As she passes out, an enormous beam of white
light erupts out of her chest and flies into
space, impacting on the full moon above.
Then, as the entire moon starts to glow red
hot, it suddenly becomes very clear how the
world is supposed to end.
As they say, shoot for the moon...
As pieces of the moon rain down from the heavens,
our heroes only have a few moments to do something
to save the world.
How do they manage it?
Well, they don't.
Number Five makes them all gather together
so they can travel back in time to try and
prevent the apocalypse at an earlier juncture.
"I think I have a way outta here.
But you've gotta trust me on this."
"No…"
The long term-consequences on Vanya aren't
clear, since she passes out immediately and
doesn't wake up before the end of the episode,
but it's possible she's suffered hearing damage.
That would certainly make her career as a
violinist more difficult, and add an unexpected
wrinkle to a character with the ability to
control sound.
Time travel, killers, and the future
We can assume that very few people survive
the end of the world, outside of our main
seven heroes — if you can count Ben as "surviving,"
that is.
Most of the other named characters were dead
already, including Pogo, Mom, Leonard, and
the Handler.
But what about Hazel and Cha Cha?
It's a blink and you'll miss it moment, but
a second before the blast hits Hazel and Agnes,
they disappear in a flash of blue light.
This implies they stole a Briefcase — one
of the Commission's time travel devices — from
the Handler after killing her.
We don't know where Hazel and Agnes traveled
to, but we can assume we haven't seen the
last of them.
Cha Cha's fate is far more grim.
Despite technically succeeding at her final
assignment of keeping Vanya Hargreeves alive,
we see that in her final moments, she is trying
and failing to contact HQ from a payphone.
This could be because, as Hazel predicted,
the Commission never intended to rescue them
from the apocalypse, or it could simply be
because the Handler is dead, and there's no
one to receive her call.
Either way, we unfortunately have to say "ta
ta" to Cha Cha.
But, since Hazel and Cha Cha have had long
and illustrious careers as time-traveling
assassins, it's possible that the Hargreeves
will run into these two again at an earlier
point in their lives, when the pair were still
cold-blooded killers.
Nothing can mess with a character arc quite
like time travel.
"The old man did say time travel could contaminate
the mind."
Umbrella Academy babies?
As the Hargreeves are preparing to travel
back in time, they appear for a moment to
be de-aged back to how they looked as teenagers.
It is possible that this is just supposed
to be a cool, artsy way to end the season,
a symbolic representation of how the Hargreeves
have finally been reunited together as a family,
like back when they were children.
But it's also possible that this moment is
meant to be taken very literally.
Remember that Number Five himself didn't always
look 13.
He used to be a 58-year-old man, but his age
was reset back to 13 as an unintended side
effect of the method he used to time travel.
If Five is sending his siblings back using
the same method, it's possible that they'll
be de-aged the same way he was.
From what we've seen of Five's struggles with
this situation, getting stuck in a body that's
the wrong age is not an easy problem to fix.
"It's been a rough couple of days."
If this does indeed happen, then a big conflict
for the coming season will probably be the
team trying to find a way to return to adulthood.
There might be another side effect to this,
however, and it's more unambiguously positive.
Since Ben's ghost is also hitching a ride,
if everything about these characters is reversing
to how things were when they were teens, it's
possible that he might not just be returned
to youth, but back to life as well.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.